Imamo pravna pravila koja su ona pravila
koja imaju uređeno funkcionisanje države
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanja države
koja su podložna čelu subordinacije
i koordinacije.
Subordinacija je odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti koji imamo državno
dat na različitim stepenima vlasti.
A kod koordinacije
imamo isti stepen vlasti
i imamo saradnju.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se, jel da, zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Dakle, kada je reč o ljudima,
premaćemo se ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade, kako rade i kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini stanovništvo.
Znači, taj državni aparat
čine samo neki ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim licima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u ime i za račun države.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određeni poslovi.
Dakle,
imate određeno državno službeno lice,
date mu da radi neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegov rad.
Ja se trudim
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim,
ne da se držim tih definicija službenika,
nego najprostije moguće da vam objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao, daš ga jednom
državnom stvornom licu i kažeš evo ti,
napravi to, to je tvoja nadležnost,
bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i jedna treća nekako
funkcionalna,
to uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno
u radu državnih organa,
ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno lice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službeno lice, da li oni rade isti posao?